des bus entiers réquisitionné par les
autorités chinoises pour évacuer les
habitants d'un quartier résidentiel de
shanghai
si les autorités locales ne précise pas
le nombre de personnes évacuées
l'épidémie est de retour dans la
mégalopole qui fait face ces derniers
jours un regain épidémique
une décision prise suite à la découverte
de trois nouveaux cas les premiers
depuis novembre dernier les autorités
elle recommande d'éviter tout
déplacement ne voyagez pas et ne vous
réunissez pas à moins que cela ne soit
nécessaire
cela aidera à prévenir les risques dès
le début ceux qui souhaitent rentrer
dans leurs villes d'origine doivent
obtenir un rapport de test d'acides
nucléiques négatif dans les sept jours
avant le départ les nouveaux foyers sont
apparus d'abord dont le nord du pays
dans la province d'hebei
particulièrement touchée est la capitale
est à son tour pékin a d'ailleurs
annoncé mercredi le confinement strict
de cinq quartiers de la banlieue sud
après la découverte du variant anglais
la chine fait donc face à une nouvelle
vague épidémique est l'annoncé hier 144
nouveaux cas sur son sol le pays
elle déclare aujourd'hui 4800 un décès
sur près de 90000 contaminées depuis le
début de l'épidémie